[Aplausos]
antes que nada quiero agradecerles que
estén aquí estén dando un poquito de su
tiempo para que les pueda contar un
poquito de lo que pasa adentro de mi
cabeza
creo que
los seres humanos somos seres creativos
por necesidad
es nuestra manera de expresarnos es
nuestra manera de pensar es nuestra
manera de comunicarnos muchas veces es
nuestra manera de sentir
entonces qué carajos significa pensar en
voz alta no me refiero a cuando voy
caminando en las noches saliendo del
antro pensando en que tacos me va a
comer se los prometo todos lo hacemos
pensar en voz alta para mí es el primer
paso necesario para un desarrollo
creativo
es la necesidad en mi caso de contar
historias la necesidad de dejar una
huella de lo que soy de lo que me
interesa de lo que me preocupa y
escuchen bien la palabra que estoy
usando necesidad
porque cuando algo realmente importa es
necesario
necesito hacer este proyecto necesito
hacer esta serie necesito que dejemos de
gastar nuestros recursos naturales de la
manera que lo estamos haciendo o no
vamos a tener un mundo que le vamos a
dejar a nuestros hijos vida o muerte
pero en qué momento nos sentimos
orgullosos por lo que hacemos
en qué momento sentimos felicidad por
nuestros logros
en qué momento estamos plenos por lo que
hacemos por lo que sentimos por lo que
pensamos
creo que eso solamente pasa
cuando nos dejamos de preguntar si esto
es suficientemente bueno para los demás
nos preguntamos
esto me hace feliz esto es lo que quiero
hacer en esto quiero invertir mi tiempo
pero
sí me gustaría lograr que se vayan de
aquí por lo menos con la pregunta
qué tiene que suceder para que ustedes
se arriesguen
por una de sus propias ideas
creo que toda la gente que está aquí
debe ser gente creativa
y la gente creativa somos coleccionistas
de momentos en mi caso como actor como
director me la paso por la vida
observando y viendo qué va a pasar y
digo que siento de este momento que me
hace sentir que pienso pero más
importante cómo puedo transformar esto
en una historia que yo quiera contar
porque hoy por hoy tenemos tanta
información tantas opciones tantos
caminos buenos malos mediocres que es
prácticamente imposible definir qué es
lo que realmente necesitamos
sin embargo tenemos esta necesidad
inherente de ser exitosos de sobresalir
de alguna manera
y hoy por hoy en este mundo del copy
paste y las redes sociales el éxito se
debe a que seamos diferentes a crear
algo único
porque las comparaciones están a la
orden del día senado cuenta que podemos
recibir 100 comentarios de algo bueno y
uno malo
y entonces todo todo nuestro ser se
enfoca en ese comentario malo y te vas
pensando porque esa niña dijo que tengo
orejas del fondo
y no dormí esa noche
y dije bueno chance si puedo que hacer
para el señor de los anillos' ahora que
la van a ser seria
pero con todas estas redes sociales hoy
estamos tan tan cercanos al supuesto
éxito de los demás
y siento que tenemos este rollo de que
siempre estamos llegando tarde a todo
nunca estamos satisfechos
y creo que el problema general de eso es
que nos enfocamos más en los logros de
los demás y dejamos de ver los nuestros
y entonces frustramos muchos de nuestros
procesos creativos sin siquiera darles
la oportunidad de pasar de un
pensamiento a una idea
creo que el problema es la autocrítica y
es este miedo al fracaso así que hacemos
que dejemos perdón este miedo al fracaso
es el que hace que dejemos
y que muchas de nuestras cosas no
evolucionen y dejamos de hacer cosas
excepcionales les voy a dar un ejemplo
super rápido
desde que tengo memoria escrito guiones
pensamientos poemas cartas canciones
todo lo que se puedan imaginar pero no
fue hasta hace seis años que decidí
hacer algo al respecto porque porque a
diferencia de cuando soy actor y hago un
personaje y le puedo echar la culpa a
ese personaje de todos mis problemas
emocionales y ustedes no van a saber
cuál es la realidad de la ficción lo que
estaba escrito en esos libros era yo era
mi esencia eran mis debilidades eran mis
inseguridades eran mis pasiones era mi
amor era mi desamor
y la verdad es que soy bien cursi y
entonces me daba pánico enseñárselo al
mundo pero para que esas ideas progresen
se las tienes que enseñar a alguien y
esas personas te van a juzgar y qué pasa
si no eres bueno lo suficientemente
talentoso
ese es un problema muy grave porque
entonces
tenemos
nos empezamos a juzgar y tenemos este
pánico terrible a no ser lo
suficientemente interesantes
tenía tanto miedo a no ser suficiente
que deje de hacer cosas que ahora sí que
perdón el romanticismo pero actor que me
hacían sentir vivo
eso es eso es una de las cosas que esta
sociedad ha creado la sociedad nos ha
enseñado que si somos vulnerables
entonces somos débiles y la historia
habla de que si obviamente la
supervivencia del más fuerte y eso está
en nuestro adn pero gente creativa creo
que estamos cometiendo un grave grave
error
no podemos basarnos en eso cuando
estamos en procesos creativos porque
cuando nos adueñamos de nuestra
vulnerabilidad de nuestras
imperfecciones y las transformamos si
les damos una voz
y las hacemos una historia o un vestido
o un movimiento social estamos
convirtiendo algo que antes nos pesaba
algo que era una carga para nosotros
algo que sufríamos en algo bueno
en algo bonito en algo hermoso en algo
que podría ser inspiración al que cree
en algo único
las historias que valen la pena son las
que más nos cuestan trabajo porque
porque están arraigadas en sentimientos
verdaderos y no se preocupen cuando eso
pasa la gente los va a poder identificar
cuando ustedes lloran en una película no
lloran porque sienten lo mismo que
matthew mcconaughey en interestelar
cuando recibe el vídeo a su hija se da
cuenta que perdió toda su vida ustedes
lloran porque ese actor
saco un sentimiento tan real para él que
como les decía nunca vamos a saber qué
es pero de sus adentros tan verídico tan
importante que ustedes lo identificaron
y lo sustituyeron por sus propias
vivencias
y tú se nos hace un nudo en la garganta
eso es arte
es lo mismo que pasa con escuchar una
canción dicen ese güey dijo exactamente
lo que yo estaba pensando desde hace
tiempo y no lo podía decir y entonces
van y se la dedican a su novia porque a
la mamá
a su ex novia porque la odian y no la
han superado no se haga
porque será que cuando más nos afecta
algo el último que queremos es sentirlo
porque tenemos este pánico hacer
nosotros porque para mí ese es el
verdadero camino al arte y no digo que
tenemos que estar sufriendo todo el día
nuestros domingos de vacío para escribir
cosas buenas
lo que digo es que debemos de ser
honestos con nuestros sentimientos
para crear cosas relevantes
y aquí voy con tres tesoro
aquí el primer paso para poder crear
es perderle el miedo a la imperfección
y al fracaso
el campo
uno de los genios de pixar dice si no
estás experimentando el fracaso entonces
estás haciendo algo peor
estás viviendo a costa de no cometerlos
les cuento esto porque durante mucho
tiempo yo siempre estaba pensando en ok
que es el momento perfecto para que yo
haga el siguiente paso de mi vida un
taller más de actuación y entonces voy a
hacer casting un taller más de dirección
y entonces me arriesgo a hacer mi ópera
prima o mi favorita en esta última
semana y de seguramente lo que le ha
pasado a todos estamos aquí un tag más y
escribo el mío
pánico de verdad
pero cuando dejamos eso de lado dejamos
un pretexto y nos enfrentamos a la
realidad de las cosas si lo hacemos de
esa manera podemos aprender y no tenemos
que ser los eternos estudiantes
realmente nos arriesgamos y nos vamos y
creamos
pero para hacer eso les voy a dar un
consejo gigantesco
lo hacemos en nuestras clases de
actuación y funciona y no importa lo que
hagan pero
pensé permiso a fallar
pensé permiso a equivocarse
porque tenemos esta presión
y cuando fallamos y fallamos de vez en
cuando
el problema viene que justamente este
este momento d
de realidad tenemos tenemos esta presión
de ser exitosos que tomamos cada error o
cada falla como una derrota
en vez de disfrutar la experiencia
vivida tienen que tener permiso a
equivocarse porque entonces van a quitar
ese peso gigantesco de encima y van a
empezar a disfrutar el proceso y el
proceso creativo va a fluir muchísimo
mejor
no todas las sillas van a ser buenos
pero como lo van a saber si no salen de
su cabeza por eso les insisto en que
tienen que pensar en voz alta el simple
hecho de poder decir una idea hace que
comencemos a cuestionarlo
y pasa de ser un pensamiento a una
propuesta
y ese cuestionamiento de esa idea va a
ser que avance que evolucione o que
muera
susan batson que es una de las actrices
más importantes del mundo que trabaja
con nicole kidman jamie foxx obra dice
que cuando llegamos a un proceso
creativo y estamos atorados lo más
importante que podemos hacer es
preguntarnos es qué pasaría si esa
pregunta hace que pensemos un poquito
más outside the box y de alguna manera
podamos
pues confrontar lo que estamos haciendo
entienden qué pasaría si mi personaje
hablara de esta manera qué pasaría si
hago una alberca volada en vez de una
alberca normal qué pasaría si hubiera
invertido en tulum hace 20 años qué
pasaría si mezclo avellanas con cocoa y
creo una cosa preciosa llamada nutella
exacto imagínense un mundo sin hotel
estaremos perdidos
pero creo que eso es lo más importante y
en la vida es que justamente cuando
escogemos entre estas cosas me rompería
se durmió gracias
yo sé que todo esto suena super
romántico
pero de qué sirve si no podemos vender
esas ideas
porque a la hora de la hora toda idea es
un producto que pasa si no sabemos
defender las enfrentarlas adaptarlas
como vamos a hacer que alguien esté
dispuesto a aportar su tiempo y su
dinero en una visión y no se equivoque
porque el desarrollo creativo es
simplemente para que alguien más vea lo
que ustedes están tramando vea su punto
de vista
algo que encontré que ayuda muchísimo es
que no tengan que nada más estar
contando su idea sino que la visualicen
y si ya se soy de los pocos que no trajo
nada ven todos podemos aprender de los
errores
gracias
pero
visualizar una idea es súper importante
en mi trabajo hacemos una cosa que se
llama una biblia donde detallamos todo
lo que tiene que proceder para que
hagamos una serie así como un chef hace
no sé un menú de degustación para ver
que le funcione que no un arquitecto
hace una maqueta que no la hace para él
la hace para que los inversionistas vean
qué está pasando con este edificio y
cómo se va a ver
hagamos un ejercicio si ustedes leyeran
el mismo libro que yo todos le diéramos
el mismo libro no importa que tan
descriptivo sea todos nos vamos a
imaginar cosas distintas en cambio
cuando vieron la película de avatar
nunca se cuestionaron como se ven en los
avatar james cameron creó un universo
se los dio y ustedes lo aceptaron
y visualizaron esa idea y no solamente
fue una película con una idea
revolucionó la manera de hacer cine en
el mundo
ahora súper importante nadie logra nada
en el mundo solos
así que así como un proyecto puede ser
individuo no es individual se tiene que
ser con un grupo las ideas tienen que
salir de nuestra cabeza se tienen que
desarrollar se tienen que dialogar con
gente adecuada
gente que pueda aportar
que pueda cuestionar
júntense con gente que sea más
inteligente que ustedes para que
realmente puedan proponer cosas que
valgan la pena no hagan un equipo de
gente que usted esté en que estar
motivando busquen gente que esté
motivada por su idea porque entonces van
a dar ese extra
jim collins dice busquen a la gente
indicada para estar en el mismo camión
la gente indicada en los asientos
indicados los van a llevar a su destino
y la única manera de crear esta sinergia
es cuando rompemos nuestras limitantes y
enfrentamos nuestros pensamientos con la
realidad cuando tenemos esa entrega y
esa pasión y creemos en lo que estamos
hablando contagiamos a la gente que está
en nuestro alrededor
creamos equipos que están dispuestos a
trabajar en un solo objetivo y es a esa
propuesta pasa de un pensamiento
individual a un pensamiento colectivo
literalmente 10 días termine de filmar
una serie creada escrita dirigida
producida y actuada por mí
para amazon
y si ustedes me han dicho hace cinco
años
que estaba en la cocina de mi casa
escribiendo con mi hermano
tiempo después iba a estar yo
sony pictures international los ángeles
al lado del creador de los avengers del
planeta de los simios' y que después uno
de los streams más grandes del mundo se
iba a pelear por desarrollar la idea de
ojo alguien que nunca
había escrito nada profesionalmente y
dos alguien que alguien que vivió en
pánico
por 27 años de enseñarle que cualquier
cosa que salía de su mente a quien sea
les diría que es nunca me hubiera
imaginado sin así que no tengan miedo a
hacer ustedes con sus defectos y con sus
virtudes
no tengan miedo a tener una voz
no tengan miedo a ser rechazados porque
los mercados cambian y nunca sabemos qué
es lo que realmente va a querer el mundo
después
o sea que no importe donde vengan
abracen lo
convierten en algo bonito y preocúpense
por donde van
la gente nunca va a saber todo el
esfuerzo verídico que hubo detrás de
algo
no ven hacia los lados y no se comparen
porque es y tampoco juzguen porque nunca
nunca saben lo que tuvo que hacer esa
otra persona para estar donde está
pero creen se las oportunidades que
nadie más les daría apuesten por sus
ideas hagan equipo y apoyarse mutuamente
de verdad todos ayuden sé
porque cuando hacemos eso
uno nunca sabe de dónde puede venir una
palabra que te dé confianza para
desbordar el genio creativo que tenemos
así que sean honestos con lo que sienten
pero sean lo suficientemente
inteligentes para hacer ideas que puedan
ser un negocio y les dé una auto
sustentabilidad para poder crear y hacer
lo que ustedes quieren sin diluirse
pero más importante de todo y esta frase
se la voy a robar a mi papá
a la vida se viene a tomar decisiones
así que nadie deje que alguien más
decida cuál es su siguiente paso que
nadie decida qué carrera estudiar
que nadie decida que les interesa que
nadie decida que en que quieren
implementar su tiempo que nadie decida
qué historias tienen que contar porque
todos tenemos una voz y lo más
importante
es que tenemos algo que decir y lo único
que tenemos que hacer es buscar hacia
nuestros adentros y buscar cosas que
realmente nos muevan y no tengamos miedo
a decirlas en voz alta pero lo más
importante
no dejen que nadie decida lo que los
hace felices gracias
[Aplausos]